O
SUCH A THING?
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN BYRON
DONALDS AND FOX NATION HOST TOMI
LAHREN BOTH JOIN ME NOW.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
THE TESTIMONY OR THE QUESTIONING
BY SENATOR RAND PAUL WAS
COMPELLING, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DO NOT NEED THE GOVERNMENT TO
TELL THEM WHAT THE TRUTH IS BUT
FOR SOME REASON OUR GOVERNMENT
THINKS THAT THIS NINA JANKOVICZ
IS THE PERFECT PERSON ACCORDING
TO MAYORKAS WHO WOULD BE HER
BOSS TO TELL US WHAT THE TRUTH
IS WHAT SAY YOU CONGRESSMAN
DONALDS?
>> WE DON'T NEED NINA JANKOVICZ.
WE DON'T NEED MAYORKAS.
HE FRANKLY CAN'T TELL THE TRUTH
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
HOW CAN WE RELY ON HIM AND HIS
DEPARTMENT TO TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THE TRUTH ABOUT ANYTHING.
THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE JOKE.
THE REAL ISSUE HERE IS THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE FAILED ACROSS THE
BOARD, JUDGE.
AND THEY HAVE TO PUT OUT
NARRATIVES AND TALKING POINTS
AND THEY ARE THE ONES THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE TO USE THE
EMOTIONS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO TRY TO WIN ELECTIONS.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T DO IT WITH
FACT.
THEY CAN'T DO IT WITH THE BASE.
THEY THINK NINA JANKOVICZ IS
GOING TO PULL THEM OUT OF THE
FIRE.
BUT THEY HAVE FAILED BROADLY AND
EVERYBODY KNOWS THE TRUTH NOW.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW, THAT
IS A GOOD POINT.
I MEAN, TOMI, THEY ARE PICTURING
ON EMOTION AND THAT IS WHAT THIS
WHOLE THING IS ABOUT ABORTION.
I WANT TO STICK WITH MAYORKAS
FOR A MINUTE.
I MEAN THAT GUY TO ME HASN'T
TOLD THE TRUTH SINCE HE SHOWED
UP.
THE BORDER IS SECURE YOU KNOW,
IN A FEW DAYS TITLE 42 DROPS,
AND, YOU KNOW, THEY PLAN ON NOT
LISTENING TO THE FEDERAL JUDGE
APPARENTLY, THEY ARE REALLY
READY TO HANDLE 18,000 ILLEGALS
A DAY.
>> LISTEN, MAYORKAS IS WAY IN
OVER HIS HEAD.
AND HE SHOULD PULL A JEN PSAKI
AND MAYBE JUST GO WORK AT MSNBC
OR ANOTHER LIBERAL NEWS OUTLET
SO HE CAN ACTUALLY PEDDLE
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION.
NOT ONLY THIS, DO WE NOT NEED
THE GOVERNMENT TO TELL US WHAT
THE TRUTH IS IF THE LAST TWO
YEARS SERVE AS EVERYTHING THEY
TOLD US WAS A LIE OR
DISINFORMATION OR CONSPIRACY
THEORY, MOST OF THAT HAS TURNED
OUT TO ACTUALLY BE TRUE.
SO THE REVERSE IS ACTUALLY THE
CASE WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN PEDDLING US
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
FORCE FEEDING DOWN OUR THROATS
WITH BIG TECH ON THEIR SIDE HOPE
GLI ELON MUSK THAT IS GOING TO
CHANGE AND THAT'S PROBABLY WHY
THEY NEED THIS WON TO TELL US
WHAT THE TRUTH IS BECAUSE THEY
ARE TERRIFIED THAT THE WARNS OF
BIG TECH MIGHT NOT BE REFEREEING
FOR THEIR SIDE ANYMORE.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW,
CONGRESSMAN DONALDS, TOMI MAKES
A GREAT POINT.
THAT IS THAT WE HAVE FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA COMING
OUT A FEW WEEKS AGO IN A SPEECH
SAYING YOU KNOW, I'M A FIRST
AMENDMENT SPEECH ABSOLUTIST, A
FREE SPEECH ABSOLUTIST BUT WE
GOT TO MODERATE THE CONTENT.
AND WITHIN A WEEK OR TWO, MUSK
IS BUYING TWITTER AND NOW ALL OF
A SUDDEN WE HAVE THIS
DISINFORMATION CZAR.
HOW FAR LEFT CAN WE POSSIBLY GO
TO CUT BACK ON THE FIRST
AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION?
>> LISTEN, THE POLITICAL LEFT
KNOWS NO BOUNDS.
THEY WILL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES
TO WIN ELECTIONS, TO IMPLEMENT
THEIR AGENDA.
NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
EVEN BARACK OBAMA WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT, HE LIED ABOUT
PREMIUMS.
HE LIED ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH OBAMACARE.
ON
OBAMACARE RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE NEVER PAID MORE FOR MY
HEALTH INSURANCE.
MY DEDUCTIBLES HAVE NEVER BEEN
HIGHER.
HE WAS NOT TELLING THE TRUTH.
YET, HE SPENDS THE REST OF HIS
POST POLITICAL CAREER TRYING TO
LECTURE US.
>> THE POLITICAL LEFT, THE
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS, JUST WANT
TO IMPLEMENT THEIR AGENDA.
THEY DO NOT CARE WHO THEY HAVE
TO LIE TO.
THEY DO NOT CARE WHAT AGENCIES
THEY NEED TO CREATE IN ORDER TO
GET THE JOB DONE.
>> Judge Jeanine: TOMI, IN LINE
WITH THAT IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO, THE DOXXING OF THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES, OF THE
CONSERVATIVE ONES WHO, YOU KNOW,
WAS APPARENTLY WE DON'T KNOW YET
FOR SURE SIGNED ON TO THE ALITO
DECISION OVERRULING ROE V. WADE
IN CASEY, I MEAN, IT COMES FROM
THE TOP, LITERALLY.
THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM STARTING
WITH MAXINE WATERS GET IN THEIR
FACES.
HOW DO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NOT
SEE THIS?
>> LISTEN, THE PARTY THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE SO LOVING AND SO
TOLERANT IS ANYTHING BUT.
IT'S ALSO A TERM CALLED
GASLIGHTING.
AND THEIR NEW CZAR OF TRUTH DOES
THAT WELL.
WHEN SHE SAYS THAT CONSERVATIVES
AND REPUBLICANS ARE THE ONES
TRYING TO WEAPONIZE FOR PROFIT
MAYBE THE DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD
TO RAISE MONEY FOR BLM OR EVERY
TIME THERE IS A SCHOOL SHOOTING
TO RAISE MONEY FOR THEIR
ANTI-GUN GROUP OR NOW WITH THIS
LATEST SUPREME COURT LEAK TO
RAISE MONEY FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND OTHER ENTITIES
THAT THEY SUPPORT.
CALLED GASLIGHTING, THE
DEMOCRATS DO IT VERY WELL
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE SO MANY
LOW INFORMATION VIEWERS AND
STLEERTS BUY INTO IT UP TO US TO
GET THE MESSAGING BETTER ON OUR
SIDE.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT IS S